nétait rien pour la société au fond et
la disparition de rien bah ça n'inquiète
[Musique]
personne quand les enquêtes
dfonctionnent quand la justice
dfonctionne et bien on a des tueurs qui
passent au travers des mailles du filet
c'est naturel et c'est normal on sait
maintenant que trois tueurs en série se
sont croisés dans Lyonne moi je me
retrouve face ceint tuure en série mais
sans sans y croire je me dis que cet
émil Louis peut être tu en série enfin
mais en tout cas c'est la dernière chose
qu' me reste à faire finalement c'est
aller lui poser la question euh on vient
vous voir je suis
journaliste j'aimerais discuter avec
vous si c'est non écouteire là
foutez-moi la ça a fait plus de 20 ans
ouais alors qu'est-ce qu'on vient de
faire chier encore
[Musique]
là